hello, how are you, greets you sali jaramillo
with his brief informative for today tuesday
may 4 the palms hotel in las vegas
was sold to a california tribe
verbard resorts announced this agreement for
650 million with san manuel van oordt
mission indians this sale is subject to
regulatory approval however
expected to be finalized by this year
the cosmopolitan is hosting a
job fair today starting
at 10am until
2pm within the show it is used to
hire staff for different
positions in different areas you must  fill out
the application prior to the event at
cosmopolitan las vegas' dotcom
william beresford is also
hosting several job fairs
from today through thursday these will be from
9 am to 4 pm inside
the mandalay bay convention center
looking for waitresses security guards
security
poolside servers receptionists among others for
a full list of jobs
available  You can also visit
our diagonal industrial dotcom page
in Spanish.
Now we're going with your weather forecast. It
's expected a sunny day. The
temperatures will rise to 90
degrees again. It
's important to drink a lot of water and be
careful. Have a nice day.
his brief
informative for disney out in spanish
[Music]